donc à la ghana gravel l'émission
enquête est avec nous qu'on soit radin
soit vous avez obtenu à l'un des
documents qui démontrent que d'autres
enquêtes de l'upac vise encore les
libéraux du québec
quatre parlementaires donc de l'époque
de jean charest de 2003 à 2012 sont
visés par ces enquêtes donc de l'upac un
seul nom est connu celui de madame
nathalie normandeau
selon des documents policiers un membre
du caucus de philippe couillard fait
partie de ces quatre personnes donc qui
sont visés par des enquêtes de l'upac
les trois autres ne sont plus en
politique aujourd'hui
il ya donc trois enquêtes on connaît les
deux premières joutes et hier celle qui
n'est pas connue celle enquête justesse
ce sont en gros des enquêtes sur de
l'abus de confiance corruption fraude
transactions illégales et financement
donc illégal du parti libéral du québec
peut-être vous dire que depuis un
certain temps ipaq ratisse de plus en
plus larges dans leur mire il ya des
organisateurs politiques des dirigeants
d'entreprise et aussi des hauts
fonctionnaires
il est même question dans les documents
que j'ai obtenu de versements d'argent
dans des comptes dans un paradis fiscal
soit oubbana merci beaucoup et 20 en
soirée